you have seen the style of this debate
Donald Tusk Prime Minister Morawiecki
government of Donald Tusk
Mateusz Morawiecki and Mr.
mutual taunts of malice
lack of objectivity
This is a style of practice
Policy between the PIN and the Platform
which in many fundamental matters
How the European Union Ukraine
energy policy
covids were not different from each other
They voted for the same laws.
to grab their heads in the media and pretend
yy great creature do you lead a great dispute
we also have here snap platforms parties
which are not a real alternative
This real alternative
is confederation
The only political force in Poland
which proposes a generational change
Qualitative change and mental change
Economic freedom
Simple and low taxes
voluntary SOS for entrepreneurs
Cheaper apartments
Constitutional protection of cash
Social Security for Ukrainians
Moderation in immigration policy
For a responsible immigration policy package
defending farmers against Polish bureaucrats
Government and Brussels
Freedom to use our cars
Freedom of movement
Freedom for Poles
A decent life in your own country